prepare yourself so I'm about to get
nasty
every year there are Oscar nominations
announced and most of the times I
Huskers but today I'm like dang it this
sucks
now when the Dark Knight was snubbed I
was upset along with lots of people and
a lot of people think that that's why
the Academy expanded the Best Picture
category to ten possible nominations
there are a few things I'm a little
upset about this year I'd like to go
over them with you let's start off with
the obvious one that you I'm sure you've
heard from many people Christopher Nolan
not being nominated for Best Director
his movie Inception nominated for Best
Picture nominated for Best Screenplay
nominated for a whole bunch of other
technical Awards however they don't
nominate the man who put it all together
who created it who thought about it for
like 10 years or something they don't
nominate him fail Academy I just don't
understand that they had to have known
that people were gonna like freak out on
top of that they didn't nominate Danny
Boyle the director of 127 hours they
don't like the screenplay 127 hours the
main actor and the picture but not the
director why it's like they're trying a
new thing this year or something to see
what people say I don't understand it's
really weird Scott Pilgrim very
criminally underrated the box office had
some of the best visual effects and
editing and sound editing and sound
mixing I have seen in a movie in a very
long time and yet nothing Scott Pilgrim
is one of the best movies of 2010 we've
had some of the best editing I've ever
seen in a film it was just everything in
that movie was like a feast for the ears
and the eyes nothing okay
I am actually legitimately upset the
Academy if I saw never the Academy right
now I'd be like what the heck man now
this next one is a really big one for me
now I know shutter island' got mildly
positive reviews which I don't
understand Leonardo DiCaprio that man
right there gave one of the best
performances I have ever seen in a movie
it is literally almost like a crime if
anything in shredder I should have been
nominated it was Leonardo DiCaprio I
mean seriously
I have never been more upset at the
Oscars of the Academy Awards ever do you
recall this it has classic written all
over an Academy I'm telling you if you
don't nominate this movie like you
didn't nominate the Dark Knight I am
never watching the Academy Awards again
that was me in my inception review they
did nominated for a great many things
but they had a major fail and not
nominated Christopher Nolan who is
without a doubt one of the best
directors working today also 127 hours
wasn't nominated for Best Cinematography
it seemed like they just picked the same
like 5 movies and we're like we'll just
throw with us everywhere it's dumb so
this is my message to the Academy Awards
you suck big time I felt really good